If you think your life is confusing, consider for a moment what happened to Congressman Ernest Istook last year. He's a Republican from Oklahoma. He believes that the Federal budget needs to be balanced. He believes it so fiercely that last year he formally proposed an amendment to the Constitution that would require a balanced Federal budget.
如果你觉得自己的生活很混乱，不妨花点时间想想国会议员欧内斯特·伊斯托克（Ernest Istook）去年遭遇的事情。他是来自俄克拉荷马州的共和党人。他坚信联邦预算需要平衡。他对此非常执着，以至于去年他正式提出了一项宪法修正案，要求实现联邦预算平衡。
And then, just a few weeks later, he voted, along with the majority of the House of Representatives, for a Federal budget that would create the largest deficit in American history: $347 billion. Even without the money that we were spending on the war in Iraq, it would have been the largest in history. I talked to him about it at the time.
然而，仅仅几周后，他和众议院的大多数成员一起，投票通过了一项联邦预算，该预算将创造美国历史上最大的赤字：3470亿美元。即使不包括我们在伊拉克战争上的开支，这也将是史上最大的赤字。当时我就此采访过他。
Certainly a majority of the American people and a majority of the people in Congress, on principle, say that they support a balanced budget amendment. That's great. But it's just like the Scarlet O'Hara syndrome, I'll worry about that tomorrow. Well, tomorrow never comes.
当然，大多数美国人和国会中的大多数人，在原则上都表示支持平衡预算修正案。这很好。但这就像斯嘉丽·奥哈拉综合症（Scarlet O'Hara syndrome），“我明天再担心那件事吧”。可是，明天永远不会到来。
Right. But if you and so many other people in Congress believe that we should not have a deficit, why not just vote against this budget with this deficit?
没错。但如果你和国会中其他许多人认为我们不应该有赤字，为什么不直接投票反对这个有赤字的预算呢？
Yeah. I voted for the budget not because I support the level of spending in the budget, but because I understand in the process that we go through in Washington DC, if we did not adopt this budget resolution, we would end up with higher spending levels. Those are the political dynamics that are afoot.
是的。我投票支持该预算并不是因为我支持预算中的支出水平，而是因为我明白我们在华盛顿特区的运作流程，如果我们不通过这项预算决议，最终的支出水平会更高。这就是现实中的政治动态。
And this doesn't really seem like an answer to the question. It is all that he would say. We went around and around on it, me asking why not just vote for less money, him saying this was the lowest amount Congress could agree on.
这似乎并不是对问题的回答。这全是他唯一能说的话。我们围绕这个问题兜圈子，我问他为什么不直接投票支持减少开支，他则说这是国会能达成一致的最低金额。
For our program this week, all of us who work on the radio show wanted to do a program that would give a sense of what the hell is going on in the economy, because everything that we read about it or hear about it seems so contradictory. You've got deficit hawks, like Congressman Istook, supporting a tax cut from President Bush that could boost the deficit by a third. You've got the economy growing steadily for over two years now. In fact, last summer, it was growing really fast, 8.2% growth, which should have created jobs, but somehow it didn't and nobody exactly understands why. Then, two months ago, the economy finally started creating jobs. And again, nobody really understands why it happened then.
对于我们这周的节目，电台的所有制作人员都想制作一期节目，让大家感受一下经济到底发生了什么，因为我们所读到或听到的一切似乎都非常矛盾。你既有像伊斯托克议员那样支持布什总统减税（可能会使赤字增加三分之一）的赤字鹰派，也有经济已经稳步增长两年多的现实。事实上，去年夏天经济增长非常快，达到了8.2%，这本应创造就业机会，但不知何故却没能实现，没有人确切知道原因。然后，两个月前，经济终于开始创造就业机会了。同样，也没有人真正明白为什么是在那个时候发生的。
And then there's this. At the same time the job picture's been so bleak over the last few years because of low interest rates and cheap mortgages, lots of middle-class people had money in their pockets. And so, even during the recession, people bought homes and cars in record numbers which is not what a recession used to mean.
还有一点。尽管过去几年由于低利率和廉价抵押贷款，就业前景非常黯淡，但许多中产阶级手里仍有钱。因此，即使在经济衰退期间，人们购买房屋和汽车的数量也创下了纪录，这与我们过去对经济衰退的理解不同。
Welcome to WBEZ Chicago. It's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our radio program, a show that we call My Two Cents in which we try to get a grip on what is happening in this weird, contradictory economy with stories from three different people in three different places in the economy.
欢迎来到芝加哥WBEZ电台。这是由公共广播国际公司（Public Radio International）发行的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天在我们的广播节目中，我们带来一期名为《我的一点拙见》（My Two Cents）的节目，通过经济中三个不同领域、三个不同人的故事，试图弄清在这个奇怪且充满矛盾的经济中到底发生了什么。
Act One of our show, Dave Knows, the story of a man who might have a better grip on what is going on in the economy of middle-class America, what is going on in your personal finances, than all of the experts you ever read about in the paper or see on TV. And chances are, you have never heard his name.
节目的第一部分是“戴夫懂行”（Dave Knows），讲述了一个人可能比你在报纸上读到或电视上看到的任何专家，都更了解美国中产阶级经济和个人财务状况。而你可能从没听过他的名字。
Act Two, Stock Making Sense, in that act somebody who lost money in the stock market during the collapse of the internet economy heads off on a quest. Perhaps an even more futile quest than his original stock purchase. And he puts together a report, a stockumentary if you will.
第二部分是“股票的意义”（Stock Making Sense），讲述了一个在互联网经济崩溃期间在股市赔了钱的人踏上了一段探索之旅。这可能比他最初的购股行为更徒劳。他最终整理出一份报告，或者说是一部“股票纪录片”。
Act Three, A View From The Mop. A janitor has written a book about what it is like to work for over a decade for under $6 an hour at the same job. Stay with us.
第三部分是“来自拖把的视角”（A View From The Mop）。一位清洁工写了一本书，讲述了他在同一份工作中，以每小时不到6美元的工资干了十多年的感受。请继续收听。
Act One: Dave Knows. We wanted to begin today with this story about what is happening with middle-class Americans and their place in the economy. There are lots of different ways that you can measure how they're doing. You could examine unemployment statistics or consumer spending. You could take a poll. Or you could have a, more or less, random group of adults with all sorts of jobs call into a radio show to talk about their money situation. It turns out that somebody already does this, and he does it really, really well. His name is Dave Ramsey. His show is on over 160 stations, mostly in the south and west. The show comes out of Nashville. From Tennessee, Susan Drury put together this report.
第一部分：戴夫懂行。今天我们想从这个关于美国中产阶级及其在经济中地位的故事开始。衡量他们过得如何有很多种方法。你可以查阅失业统计数据或消费者支出。你可以进行民意调查。或者，你可以让一群背景各异、职业随机的成年人打进电台热线，谈谈他们的经济状况。事实证明，已经有人在做这件事了，而且做得非常好。他的名字叫戴夫·拉姆齐（Dave Ramsey）。他的节目在160多个电台播出，主要集中在南部和西部地区。节目是在纳什维尔制作的。来自田纳西州的苏珊·德鲁里（Susan Drury）整理了这份报道。
To me, a daily show about personal finance is, by definition, boring. And this program is not boring, it pulls you in. Here's Lynne, a typical caller. She and her husband sold their carpet store business and they don't agree on how to handle the money from the sale.
对我来说，关于个人理财的日常节目通常很无聊。但这个节目并不无聊，它很吸引人。这位是琳恩（Lynne），一位典型的听众。她和丈夫卖掉了他们的地毯店生意，但对于如何处理卖店后的钱，两人意见不合。
He is disabled, and he kind of likes to gamble a little bit. And he says it's all his to do what he wants to. I said, no, I'm not working. We need to take it and budget it out for us to live on because we have two little children. What should I do?
他残疾了，而且有点喜欢赌博。他说这些钱都是他的，他想怎么花就怎么花。我说，不，我没在工作。我们需要把它预算好，作为我们的生活费，因为我们有两个小孩。我该怎么办？
Let's just stop this right here. On any other financial show you wouldn't even hear this question because it's not about money. Her real problem is her husband. Let's hear some more.
我们先在这儿停一下。在任何其他理财节目中，你甚至不会听到这个问题，因为这根本不是钱的问题。她真正的问题是她的丈夫。我们接着听。
When you got married, the preacher said, and now you are one. It's our money. It's our kids. It's our stuff. It's our bills. It's our stuff. We work together, so no, it's not his, it's ours. And if he's a real man, what he'll do is sit down and the two of you, together, decide what this is going to be used for, for the good of the family.
你们结婚时，牧师说过，现在你们是一体了。这是我们的钱。这是我们的孩子。这是我们的东西。这是我们的账单。我们一起工作，所以不，这不是他的，是我们的。如果他是个真正的男人，他应该坐下来，和你一起决定这笔钱如何使用，为了家庭的利益。
And this seems like just answer she wants to hear. But then the conversation takes a turn as it often does on this show. Dave knows that the money is never just about the money. So why is the husband holding on to the money? Well, that can't just be about the money either. Dave runs another theory by her. Maybe she's part of the problem.
这看起来正是她想听到的答案。但随后谈话发生了一个转折，就像这个节目中常发生的那样。戴夫知道这钱的问题从来都不只是关于钱。那么为什么丈夫紧抓着钱不放呢？好吧，那也不可能只是关于钱。戴夫向她提出了另一个理论。也许她自己就是问题的一部分。
You may be kind of a tightwad and you've got the thing turned down too tight.
你可能有点守财奴，把钱抓得太紧了。
I am.
确实是。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
That's definitely.
肯定的。
And his reaction to that is rebellion. You need to loosen up a little and he needs to come to the table and be a grown-up. Is there disability income coming in?
他对此的反应是反抗。你需要放松一点，而他需要坐到桌边表现得像个成年人。有残疾补贴收入进来吗？
Yes. Uh-huh. Now there is.
是的。嗯，现在有了。
OK. Are we sharing that?
好的。我们在共享这笔钱吗？
Well, it comes to me, and so I just budget it for each week.
嗯，钱汇给我，我就按周做预算。
OK. What you need to do, though, is it doesn't need to be I budget anymore. It needs to be we're budgeting because part of the rebellion from him is coming from the fact he doesn't feel like he's getting control. The only control he has is over that carpet store money, and he's grasping at trying to have some sense of dignity and control.
好的。但是你需要做的是，不再是你单方面做预算。我们需要共同制定预算，因为他反抗的一部分原因是他觉得自己失去了控制权。他唯一能控制的就是那笔地毯店的钱，他正试图抓住它以获得某种尊严和控制感。
I understand.
我明白了。
This call takes just 10 minutes out of the three-hour Dave Ramsey Show. It's on Monday through Friday. It has 1.8 million listeners each week. He gets a lot of calls you'd expect to hear on a personal finance show: questions about 401-Ks, bankruptcies and mortgage rates. But then there is the classic call, the one he gets all the time.
这个通话只占戴夫·拉姆齐三小时节目的10分钟。节目每周一到周五播出。每周有180万听众。他收到了许多你在个人理财节目中预料到的来电：关于401-K退休金计划、破产和抵押贷款利率的问题。但接着就是那种他经常收到的经典来电。
I need your advice on a credit situation that my wife and I have gotten ourselves into.
我需要你对我和我妻子陷入的信贷困境提供建议。
OK.
好的。
This is Scott. He and his wife have student loans and debts from a failed business. And when they lost their jobs last year, they started living off their credit cards. Scott just got another job, but he owes almost as much in debt as he'll make in a year.
这是斯科特（Scott）。他和妻子有学生贷款和生意失败留下的债务。去年他们失业时，开始靠信用卡生活。斯科特刚找到另一份工作，但他欠下的债务几乎和他一年赚的钱一样多。
OK. So you're at 55K and you owe 45K?
好的。所以你们年入5.5万美元，欠债4.5万美元？
Oh, yeah.
噢，是的。
All right. First, get $1,000 cash for miniature emergencies. Cut up your credit cards, and never again are you going to do this.
好吧。首先，准备1000美元现金以备小额紧急情况。剪掉信用卡，永远不要再这样做。
OK.
好的。
It has to be a healthy level of anger, and I am getting out of this mess, and I'm never going to live like this again. And we're going to build up some savings. And it's going to take you about three years of sacrifice and living on a budget. And no vacation, and no new anything, and very little eating out, and rice and beans, and beans and rice. And on 55K, you can be debt-free in about three years.
必须要有健康的愤怒，告诉自己我要摆脱这个烂摊子，我再也不要这样生活了。我们要开始储蓄。这将需要你三年的牺牲，并过着预算生活。没有假期，不买任何新东西，很少外出就餐，就吃米饭和豆子，豆子和米饭。在5.5万的年收入下，你可以在三年内还清所有债务。
OK.
好的。
This is what Dave tells everybody every time, the same thing over and over. Live on a budget. Cut up the cards. Work extra. Pay it off and save. Rice and beans, beans and rice, this is his sermon.
这就是戴夫每次告诉所有人的话，同样的事情一遍又一遍。过预算生活。剪掉信用卡。做兼职。还清债务并储蓄。米饭和豆子，豆子和米饭，这就是他的布道。
In the world of The Dave Ramsey Show there's one specter that haunts the US economy, and that is debt, personal debt. It's at record levels these days, $8 trillion nationwide. And for the first time ever, if you added up everyone's debt in this country, it would be greater than our annual disposable income. And Dave's got a story that makes people trust him on this subject, a story he tells often on the radio, and which he told me when we sat down for an interview.
在“戴夫·拉姆齐秀”的世界里，有一个幽灵在折磨着美国经济，那就是债务，个人债务。这些天债务达到了创纪录的水平，全国总计8万亿美元。这是有史以来第一次，如果你把这个国家每个人的债务加在一起，将超过我们每年的可支配收入。戴夫有一个故事，使人们在这个话题上信任他，他在广播中经常讲这个故事，当我们坐下来采访时，他又对我讲了一次。
The way we ended up teaching this stuff was that we went broke. Sharon and I started with nothing in our 20s, early 20s, and started buying and selling real estate. And by the time we were 26 years old, we had a little over $4 million worth, a little over $1 million net worth. I was making, the best year I ever had in the real estate business, I made $250 thousand taxable cash income that year. That's a lot of money for a kid from Antioch, Tennessee.
我们最终教导这些东西的原因是我们破产了。莎伦（Sharon）和我在20多岁出头时一无所有，开始买卖房地产。到我们26岁时，我们拥有价值400多万美元的资产，净资产超过100万美元。我在房地产行业做得最好的一年，纳税后的现金收入是25万美元。对于一个来自田纳西州安提阿的孩子来说，这是一大笔钱。
He bought a Jaguar. They went to Hawaii a couple of times. They bought a house, and then a bigger house. He was taking out a lot of short-term real estate loans. He would use the loans to buy property, fix it up, and re-sell it all within 90 days. Then the bank got sold, and they called all his loans in it once, and he couldn't pay back the money.
他买了一辆捷豹。他们去过夏威夷几次。他们买了一套房子，然后又买了一套更大的。他借了很多短期房地产贷款。他用这些贷款买房、修缮，并在90天内转卖出去。然后银行被收购了，他们要求一次性收回他所有的贷款，但他还不上钱。
And we fought for two and a half years. We fought against the process of going broke by selling things and working hard, and it didn't work. And we were sued, and sued, and sued, and sued. And we were foreclosed on repeatedly. And finally, at the bottom of that, with a brand new baby and a toddler, we were bankrupt. And so there I sat, with all these letters and licenses after my name that said I knew something about money, broke.
于是我们抗争了两年半。我们通过卖东西和努力工作来对抗破产的过程，但这没有用。我们被起诉，再起诉，再起诉，一次又一次。我们反复遭遇止赎。最后，在这一切的谷底，带着一个刚出生的婴儿和一个蹒跚学步的孩子，我们破产了。我就那样坐在那里，顶着所有那些写着我知道钱的知识的头衔和执照，破产了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
It doesn't work. And I started trying to figure out how money really works, not what someone's theory was.
那套方法不管用。我开始尝试弄清楚钱到底是怎么运作的，而不是某人的理论是什么。
This story of how he went broke and how it changed him has all the ingredients that make a great morality tale. And that is how he sees it: the sin of overspending, the dark night of the soul, and the redemption in wealth and success.
这个关于他如何破产以及这如何改变了他的故事，包含了构成伟大道德故事的所有要素。而他就是这样看待它的：过度消费的罪恶、灵魂的黑暗之夜，以及财富与成功中的救赎。
Dave's not the first person to say you shouldn't spend more than you make, but he is on a mission to change you and how you deal with money. And he is very, very specific about exactly what you should do in exactly what order. Then he's there every day to answer questions, to goad you, to push you, to harass you into following his rules.
戴夫并不是第一个说你不应该入不敷出的人，但他肩负着改变你和处理金钱方式的使命。他非常、非常具体地指出了你应该以什么样的顺序做什么。然后他每天都在那里回答问题，去激励你、督促你、逼迫你遵守他的规则。
Now, here's your host, best-selling author and financial counselor, Dave Ramsey.
现在，让我们欢迎您的主持人，畅销书作家和财务顾问，戴夫·拉姆齐。
Welcome to new millennium where debt is dumb, cash is king, and the paid-off home mortgage has taken the place of the BMW as the status symbol of choice.
欢迎来到新千年，在这里债务是愚蠢的，现金才是王道，还清贷款的房屋抵押贷款已经取代宝马，成为首选的身份象征。
Every Friday on the show, they do this thing called Debt-Free Friday. People who have followed Dave's rules call in to give their testimony of how they got into debt, how much debt they were in, how they got out, and what it feels like to be free of it. This is everyone's favorite part of the show.
每周五节目中，他们会做一个叫“债务自由星期五”（Debt-Free Friday）的环节。遵循戴夫规则的人会打电话进来，分享他们如何背上债务、背了多少债、如何摆脱债务，以及无债一身轻的感觉。这是每个人最喜欢的节目环节。
Becky, what's up with you?
贝基（Becky），你最近怎么样？
Hi, Dave. I just wanted to let you know that, after four long years, I'm finally down to the first mortgage, and I just got that refinanced on a 15-year.
你好，戴夫。我只是想让你知道，经过四个漫长的年头，我终于还清了第一笔抵押贷款，并且我刚把它重组为15年期。
Good for you. Four years, you've been working on this.
为你高兴。四年了，你一直为此努力。
Yeah. A single working mom, and I work three jobs, seven days a week.
是的。作为一个单身职场妈妈，我打三份工，一周七天。
Whoa!
哇！
In four years, Becky paid off $21,000 in debt. She's got a daughter in college and makes $34,000 from her three jobs, combined. She tells Dave she took extra jobs that let her stay at home at night with her family.
在四年里，贝基还清了2.1万美元的债务。她有个上大学的女儿，三份工作加起来年收入3.4万美元。她告诉戴夫，她做了额外的兼职，这样晚上就能留在家里陪家人。
How'd you find this job?
你是怎么找到这份工作的？
One of my friends suggested. We were trying to think of things for me to do a few years ago that never closed, and she said something about a nursing home. And I called. I made a list of the ones close to my house, and the second one I called, which is five minutes away, had an opening.
一个朋友建议的。几年前我们在想我能做什么不关门的工作，她说起了一家养老院。我就打电话。我列出了离家近的名单，打的第二个电话，离家只有五分钟路程，就有空缺。
So you guys had a brainstorming session. I mean, we got together and said how could I work? You know, you're just awesome.
所以你们进行了头脑风暴。我的意思是，你们坐在一起说我怎么才能工作？你知道，你太棒了。
Thank you.
谢谢。
It's a great place to go when you're broke, to work, and you figured that out. I'm proud of you. That's awesome.
当你破产时，工作是一个很好的去处，你发现了这一点。我为你骄傲。那太棒了。
And I just want to give anybody out there that thinks they can't do it, if I can do it, anybody can do it.
我只是想给外面那些认为自己做不到的人打气，如果我能做到，任何人都能做到。
I'll tell you. No, I'll tell you anybody can't. They've got to have the work ethic and they've got to have the character that you've got. And if they have that, they can do it. Becky, I'm proud of you. Yell at the top your lungs with all your friends.
我得告诉你。不，我会告诉你不是任何人都能做到。他们得有职业道德，得有你拥有的那种品格。如果他们有这些，他们就能做到。贝基，我为你骄傲。和你的朋友们大声欢呼吧。
OK. Are you all ready?
好的。你们都准备好了吗？
Yes.
是的。
OK. I'm debt-free!
好的。我摆脱债务了！
Debt-free!
摆脱债务了！
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
It's a party, baby! Hey!
这是个派对，宝贝！嘿！
To Dave, it's all about individual initiative, and Becky has it. And if you don't have it, he's pretty rough. Here's Tina.
对戴夫来说，这一切都取决于个人主动性，而贝基就有。如果你没有，他会相当严厉。这是蒂娜（Tina）。
I have a car payment, and I am upside down. I've heard a couple of your shows before. I want to get out of this debt, so what can I do?
我有一笔汽车贷款，而且我现在处于“资不抵债”的状态。我之前听过你的几期节目。我想摆脱债务，我能做什么？
How much do you owe on the car?
你的车欠了多少钱？
10,000 and something.
1万多一点。
And what do you think it's worth?
你觉得它现在值多少钱？
5,000 and something.
5000多一点。
Oh, my goodness. What a mess.
噢，天哪。真是个烂摊子。
She makes $800 to $900 a month, and she's paying a $368 car payment. Dave is trying to figure out how she came to owe twice as much as the car is now worth. It turns out she was in a car accident.
她一个月赚800到900美元，却要支付368美元的车贷。戴夫试图弄清楚她是怎么欠下两倍于车辆现值的钱的。原来是因为她出了一次车祸。
You wrecked it. Has it been fixed?
你把它撞毁了。修好了吗？
No.
没有。
Oh, crap. And you didn't have insurance?
噢，该死。而且你还没买保险？
I did. They sent me the money, but I spent it.
我买了。他们把钱汇给了我，但我把它花掉了。
OK. Ah.
好吧。啊。
Yeah.
是的。
I'm afraid what you're looking at is, probably, a really good part-time job, about six or eight months of 80-hour weeks.
恐怕你现在需要的是一份非常好的兼职工作，大约六到八个月每周80小时的工作量。
80-hour weeks?
每周80小时？
Yeah.
是的。
That's too much work.
那工作量太大了。
I can't help you, Tina.
我帮不了你，蒂娜。
OK. Thanks, Dave.
好吧。谢谢你，戴夫。
Thanks for the call.
谢谢你的来电。
Bye-bye.
再见。
I'm Dave Ramsey, your host. See, the bottom line is, you've got the obligation. You've got a mess, and you can't work your way out of it. You're not willing to work? I don't know anything to call that but lazy. That's all you can call that, and I can't help you.
我是戴夫·拉姆齐，你们的主持人。看，底线是，你负有责任。你搞砸了，而且你无法通过努力摆脱它。你不愿意工作？我不知道除了懒惰还能称为什么。这就是你能称呼它的一切，我帮不了你。
Dave says the financial problems we have are because we are too much like Tina and not enough like Becky. His view of the bigger economic picture is that we are all screwing up, each of us individually guilty in the same way. And this, he says, has nothing to do with the stock market, or the tech bubble, or even rising unemployment.
戴夫说，我们之所以有财务问题，是因为我们太像蒂娜，而不像贝基。他对宏观经济的看法是，我们都在把事情搞砸，我们每个人在个人层面上犯了同样的错误。他说，这与股市、互联网泡沫，甚至上升的失业率毫无关系。
How have the calls that you get changed since the boom ended?
自从繁荣结束后，你接到的来电有什么变化吗？
They haven't because the boom hasn't ended for the consumer. It was never there. Because the consumer in the '90s, the only thing that has changed for Joe and Susie is their 401K balance is lower. But they weren't using it, anyway, to live on. So day to day has not changed a bit. They're still borrowing up to their eyeballs in credit card debt. They're still buying cars they can't afford. And they're still living without a plan and no savings. And so the boom, when it was here, didn't affect them positively, except it gave them a false sense of confidence to go even crazier. And credit card debt got worse in the '90s. Now that doesn't make any sense. I mean, if there was this boom, why don't we have money to buy stuff?
没什么变化，因为繁荣对消费者来说从未结束。它从未存在过。因为90年代的消费者，乔（Joe）和苏西（Susie）唯一改变的就是他们的401K养老金余额变少了。但他们本来也没用它来生活。所以日常生活一点也没变。他们仍然在信用卡债务中越陷越深。他们仍然在买买不起的车。他们仍然在没有计划、没有储蓄的情况下生活。所以，繁荣在的时候，并没有对他们产生积极影响，除了给他们一种错误的自信去变得更疯狂。而信用卡债务在90年代变得更糟了。这说不通。我的意思是，如果曾经有过繁荣，为什么我们没有钱买东西？
Dave's message is that you are not at the mercy of the economy. It might feel like you are, but you're not. He believes this, and he gets other people to believe it. And I have to say, people, all sorts of people, like his answer. They flock to him to hear what he has to say. He tells them that there is a very simple but very difficult solution to their money problems, and it's a solution that has no room for excuses and nothing outside your control. And maybe that's what people want.
戴夫的信息是，你并不是任由经济摆布。你可能感觉是那样，但你不是。他相信这一点，并且他让其他人也相信了。我不得不说，人们，各种各样的人，喜欢他的回答。他们蜂拥而至听他怎么说。他告诉他们，他们的财务问题有一个非常简单但非常困难的解决方案，这是一个没有借口、也没有任何超出你控制的因素的解决方案。也许这就是人们想要的。
It's a Saturday morning and I'm at a Pentecostal church north of Nashville. I'm an hour early and the parking lot is nearly full by the time I get here. The lobby and the halls are filled with Dave Ramsey merchandise and the 2,500 people who are here to see Dave's five-hour, live event. He has a warm-up act, a comedian, and then he comes on.
这是一个周六的早晨，我在纳什维尔北部的一所五旬节教堂。我提前一小时到达，但我到达时停车场几乎满了。大堂和走廊里挤满了戴夫·拉姆齐的周边商品，还有2500名参加戴夫五小时现场活动的人。他有个暖场表演，一个喜剧演员，然后他登场了。
Ladies and gentlemen, will you please welcome Dave Ramsey.
女士们、先生们，请欢迎戴夫·拉姆齐。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
[SHOUTS]
[欢呼声]
Yeah! Thank you. Thanks. Well, thank you for being here today. We are going to have some fun today. I found out something about money. Money's fun if you've got some.
耶！谢谢。谢谢。嗯，谢谢你们今天来到这里。我们今天会玩得很开心。我发现了一些关于钱的事情。钱很有趣，如果你有的话。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Dave Ramsey is a brand. Not only does he do the radio show, but he writes books, holds these live events, and does curricula, and classes, and counseling sessions. It takes only four people to run the radio show, but he's got 75 more employees doing all the other stuff.
戴夫·拉姆齐是一个品牌。他不仅主持广播节目，还写书、举办这些现场活动，并提供课程、班级和咨询服务。运行电台节目只需要四个人，但他还有另外75名员工在做所有其他的事情。
We don't get it locally.
我们在当地收不到这个节目。
Jane Henkle drove five hours from her home in Indiana to see Dave live. She and her husband have been following Dave's plan for five months.
简·亨克尔（Jane Henkle）从印第安纳州的家中开车五个小时来看戴夫的现场演出。她和丈夫遵循戴夫的计划已经五个月了。
Oh, it's changed our life. I've been married 28 years and, until we met with Dave, my husband and I had never done a budget together. We had never. He did the finances, or I did the finances at different parts. We'd never done it together. We fell into the credit card trap.
噢，这改变了我们的生活。我结婚28年了，在遇到戴夫之前，我和丈夫从未一起做过预算。从来没有。他管财务，或者在不同时期我管财务。我们从来没有一起做过。我们落入了信用卡陷阱。
They started with $30,000 in credit card debt, and they've got about $20,000 left to pay off. It was a lot different before they started Dave's plan.
他们开始时有3万美元的信用卡债务，现在还剩大约2万美元。在他们开始戴夫的计划之前，情况大不相同。
A lot of stress. A lot of stress. Like, I would hide from him the credit card bills when they would come in. We're weren't totally honest with each other in our spending. We didn't have a budget to see where everything went at the end of the month, or even the end of the week. We were like, whoa! What's going on here? Oh, I'm going to the grocery store. Sorry, no money left. You know? And it's changed things around completely.
很多压力。很多压力。比如，我会把信用卡账单藏起来不让他看见。我们在消费上对彼此并不完全诚实。我们没有预算来看看月底甚至周末钱都花哪儿去了。我们就像，哇！这是怎么回事？哦，我要去杂货店。抱歉，没钱了。你知道吗？而现在一切都完全改观了。
This sense of excitement is all over this place. Like a roomful of people who are all losing lots of weight doing the exact same thing and succeeding in a world where everybody else is getting fatter. You hardly ever hear people talk about money in this way with this sense of control. And these are not rich people.
这种兴奋感弥漫在这个地方。就像满屋子的人都在通过做完全相同的事情减肥，并在一个其他人都在变胖的世界里取得了成功。你几乎听不到人们这样谈论金钱，谈论这种控制感。而且这些人并不是富人。
I'm Bobbi Hargrove.
我是鲍比·哈格罗夫（Bobbi Hargrove）。
I'm Phillip Hargrove. I've been listening, probably, about five years now. I drive a truck, so I'm up this way a lot. So I get to hear him on-- I wondered what the people on the radio was saying, that they was getting out of debt and all this. And I was like how's this work? So I love it, you know?
我是菲利普·哈格罗夫（Phillip Hargrove）。我听他的节目大概五年了。我是开卡车的，所以经常走这条路。所以我能听到他……我一直好奇广播里的人在说什么，他们说他们摆脱了债务等等。我当时想，这怎么运作的？所以我喜欢它，你知道吗？
I was going to say you're just glowing.
我正想说你看起来红光满面。
My kids, they come in, I've got the tape on the TV or I've got a CD in and everything. I live and breath this stuff, you know? It's changing everything that I've ever been taught, you know?
我的孩子们，他们进来，我正放着录音带或者CD在播。我生活和呼吸这些东西，你知道吗？这正在改变我被教导的一切，你知道吗？
In a way, it's sort of a simple thing to have a plan on how to spend and save your money. But here we are in the richest country in the world, an economic superpower, and few of us have ever really learned how to do that.
从某种程度上讲，有一个如何花钱和存钱的计划是一件简单的事情。但我们正处于世界上最富有的国家，一个经济超级大国，我们中很少有人真正学会了如何做到这一点。
When I tell my friends here in Tennessee that I'm doing a story on Dave Ramsey, one person after another tells me how he changed their lives. I hear this from a teacher, a professional musician, a reporter, a lawyer, and some farmers. Kim Turner and her husband have done Dave's plan for several years.
当我告诉我在田纳西州的朋友，我正在做一个关于戴夫·拉姆齐的故事时，一个人接着一个人告诉我他是如何改变他们的生活的。我从一位老师、一位专业音乐家、一名记者、一位律师和一些农民那里听到了这些。金·特纳（Kim Turner）和她的丈夫执行戴夫的计划已经好几年了。
You know, listening to that keeps you on the straight and narrow so that you don't stray, kind of like you go to church. Even though you already know what he's going to say, but it's just, I guess, you need to hear that every day.
你知道，听那个能让你走在正道上，这样你就不会误入歧途，有点像你去教堂。即使你已经知道他要说什么，但我觉得，你每天都需要听到那个。
A lot of people I met made this connection between going to church and listening to Dave's show, and it's not accidental. Dave's a Christian, and he doesn't shy away from quoting Scripture or talking about God on the show. As he tells callers, the Bible doesn't contain any positive references to debt. His 13-week course, Financial Peace University, is held in hundreds of churches, and he works with ministers to publicize his live events. For lots of folks, the religious angle on money is the way in. Sometimes people call in to thank Dave for his show. They call it his ministry. And he's OK with that term, although he says he doesn't want to be pigeonholed as the Christian financial guy.
我遇到很多人在去教堂和听戴夫节目之间建立了这种联系，这不是偶然的。戴夫是基督徒，他从不避讳在节目中引用经文或谈论上帝。正如他告诉来电者那样，圣经中没有任何关于债务的正面记载。他为期13周的课程“财务和平大学”（Financial Peace University）在数百个教堂举行，他与牧师合作宣传他的现场活动。对于许多人来说，金钱的宗教视角是切入点。有时人们打电话感谢戴夫的节目。他们称之为他的“事工”。他不介意这个词，尽管他说他不想被贴上“基督教理财专家”的标签。
Talk radio is one of the last intimate mediums where people can have their emotions touched along with their information. And so, in that sense, it does become a very large accountability group. And you can name it Promise Keepers, you could name it AA, you could name it therapy, it just depends on your belief system on how you would approach it and what vernacular you might put with it. Certainly, from a Christian viewpoint, what we do is minister. From a therapy viewpoint, what we do is do therapy.
脱口秀广播是最后一种亲密的媒介之一，人们可以在获得信息的同时触动他们的情感。所以，从这个意义上说，它变成了一个非常庞大的问责小组。你可以称它为“承诺守门人”（Promise Keepers）、匿名戒酒互助会（AA）或心理治疗，这取决于你的信仰体系，取决于你如何看待它以及你可能赋予它什么样的词汇。当然，从基督教的角度来看，我们所做的是“事工”。从治疗的角度来看，我们所做的是“心理治疗”。
888-825-5225. We're going to start this segment off with Kerry in Kankakee, Illinois, WKAN 1320. Hi, Kerry. How are you?
888-825-5225。我们要从伊利诺伊州坎卡基（Kankakee）的克里（Kerry）开始这一节，WKAN 1320电台。你好，克里。你好吗？
Hi. How are you?
你好。你好吗？
Good. How can I help?
很好。我能帮你什么吗？
Kerry lives with two teenage sons from an earlier marriage and with a boyfriend.
克里和前夫生的两个十几岁的儿子以及一个男朋友住在一起。
OK. And we both work. OK? He makes almost $1,000 a week, where I make $300 a week. I'm a factory worker. OK. The thing is, he's like very, to a point, controlling. We share expenses. I have to give up half of my paycheck to pay for the bills, to help pay for the bills. When I'm done doing that, then I have hardly any money left to do for my kids, or for myself, or to try and put money back. OK. He says that I can't leave because I would never be able to make it on my own. I will admit, I'm not very good at handling money. I don't know how.
好的。我们都在工作。好的？他每周赚近1000美元，而我每周赚300美元。我是一名工厂工人。好的。问题是，他在某种程度上非常、非常具有控制欲。我们分摊开支。我必须交出我一半的工资来支付账单，来帮助支付账单。当我做完这些后，我就几乎没有钱留给我的孩子、我自己，或者尝试存钱了。好的。他说我不能离开，因为我永远无法靠自己生活。我承认，我不擅长处理金钱。我不知道怎么做。
Well, let me ask you something. If you were sitting down with a cup of coffee-- how old are you?
嗯，让我问你一件事。如果你正坐着喝一杯咖啡——你多大了？
I'm 41.
我41岁。
OK. If you were to sit down over a cup of coffee with a 27-year-old, single, young lady that was living with a guy, and she told you what you just told me, what would you tell her?
好的。如果你和一个27岁、单身、和男人同居的年轻女士坐在一起喝咖啡，她告诉了你你刚才告诉我的话，你会对她说什么？
To get out. You can make it on your own.
离开。你可以靠自己过下去。
Mm-hmm. Good advice.
嗯哼。很好的建议。
OK, but how do I start on my income?
好的，但我该如何凭我的收入开始呢？
Well, I'm not positive. You don't make a lot of money, I agree with that. But let me tell you what, you're in a really unhealthy relationship. You're dealing with a guy who-- he's not hitting you, is he?
嗯，我不确定。你赚的钱不多，我同意这一点。但我告诉你，你处于一段非常不健康的感情中。你在和一个男人打交道，他……他没打你，对吧？
No.
没有。
You sure?
你确定？
Yeah.
是的。
I'm not sure I believe you.
我不确定我是否相信你。
Yeah. It's fine.
是的。没关系。
I'm sorry?
抱歉？
It's OK. I need to--
没关系。我需要……
You've got to get out of there, girl. You've got to get out of there now. OK?
你得离开那里，姑娘。你得现在就离开那里。好的？
He says, you know, that it's me. It's because--
他说，你知道，那是因为我。这是因为……
No. It's not you, darling. This guy's sick.
不。那不是你的错，亲爱的。这家伙病了。
OK.
好的。
You've got to get away from him.
你得离开他。
OK.
好的。
OK?
好的？
And you think I can survive on--
你认为我能靠……活下去吗？
Well, I can tell you this. If nothing else, you can start by going to a domestic violence shelter right now and checking in with your kids. And they will help you put together a budget, and get back on your feet, and get other employment. And you may have to take a part-time job. You may have to move into subsidized housing of some kind. I don't know exactly what the short-term, the next six months, is going to look like, but I can tell you this Kerry, you were not designed by God for this man.
嗯，我可以告诉你这一点。如果没别的，你可以先去家暴庇护所，带着你的孩子住进去。他们会帮你制定预算，重新站稳脚跟，找一份新工作。你可能不得不做一份兼职工作。你可能不得不搬进某种政府补贴住房。我不知道短期内，接下来的六个月会是什么样子，但我可以告诉你这一点，克里，上帝设计你不是为了这个男人。
OK.
好的。
Dave gives her the phone number for a women's shelter. And then, after Kerry's call, one person after another called in to tell Kerry to leave. Women who had quit abusive relationships years earlier, men and women who had grown up in violent homes, women who had felt they had been controlled by a lack of money or a fear of not being able to make it on their own, most of the calls didn't mention money at all.
戴夫给了她一个妇女庇护所的电话号码。然后，在克里的通话之后，一个人接着一个人打电话告诉克里离开。那些多年前就结束了虐待关系的女人们，那些在暴力家庭中长大的男男女女，那些觉得被金钱匮乏或害怕无法独立生活所控制的女人们，大多数电话根本没提到钱。
Susan Drury lives in Tennessee. To find out where to hear the talented Dave Ramsey on the radio every single day, go to daveramsey.com. Coming up, mild-mannered radio reporter seeks vigilante justice from the entire internet-level economy, sort of. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
苏珊·德鲁里住在田纳西州。想要知道每天在哪里可以听到才华横溢的戴夫·拉姆齐的广播，请访问daveramsey.com。接下来，温文尔雅的电台记者试图从整个互联网级别的经济中寻求私刑正义，算是吧。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司，我们的节目继续。
[MUSIC - "PENNIES FROM HEAVEN"]
[音乐 - "PENNIES FROM HEAVEN"]
With This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, a show we call My Two Cents in which we visit three people in three different places in the economy to try to understand this weird non-recovery recovery we're supposed to be in right now. We've arrived at Act Two of our show.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，一个我们称为《我的一点拙见》的节目，我们拜访了经济中三个不同领域、三个不同的人，试图理解我们现在应该处于的那种奇怪的“非复苏式复苏”。我们已经进入了节目的第二部分。
Act Two: Stock Making Sense. Right now, half of all American households own stock either through retirement plans, or through mutual funds, or that they bought themselves. But during the internet bubble, all sorts of people got into the stock market that probably never should have. Like, for instance, one of the producers of this is very radio program, Mr Alex Blumberg.
第二部分：股票的意义。目前，一半的美国住户通过退休计划、共同基金，或是自己购买股票。但在互联网泡沫时期，各种各样本来根本不应该进入股市的人都进入了。例如，这个电台节目的制作人之一，亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）先生。
If I were rich, your life would be different. I know this for sure. I know this because the source of my wealth would have an invention that changed the way you shop. This invention that would have made my fortune would also have revolutionized the distribution of carbonated beverages and would have been displayed in every supermarket, convenience store, and Walmart in America. Instead, what happened is this.
如果我有钱，你的生活会不同。我非常确定。我知道这一点，因为我的财富来源将拥有一项改变你购物方式的发明。这项让我发家的发明，也将彻底改变碳酸饮料的分销，并会展示在美国的每家超市、便利店和沃尔玛里。但相反，发生了这样的事。
I bought stock in a company on a tip in 1997. By 1998, the stock was worthless. I've spent the intervening years trying to forget that it ever happened. It was the only investment I ever made. I was the only person I know to go zero for the '90s, to have a perfect losing record for the greatest peacetime economic boom in history.
1997年，我根据一条内幕消息买了一家公司的股票。到1998年，这只股票一文不值。这些年来，我一直在努力忘记它曾经发生过。那是我唯一做过的投资。我是我认识的唯一一个在90年代交了白卷的人，在历史上最伟大的和平时期经济繁荣中，保持了完美的亏损记录。
Now I find myself wondering, probably with everyone else who lost money in the stock market collapse, what happened? Was it mass-delusion destined to crumble from the beginning? Or could things have turned out differently? What was going on inside all those factories and online boutiques we bought pieces of at the end of the last century?
现在，我开始纳闷，大概和所有在股市崩溃中赔钱的人一样，发生了什么？是注定从一开始就崩溃的大规模错觉吗？还是事情本可以有不同的结果？在我们上个世纪末买下股份的那些工厂和在线精品店里，到底在发生什么？
All right. Well, I'm putting on a head lamp because I have to go look for stuff that might be in the basement.
好的。好吧，我戴上头灯，因为我得去地下室找找可能在那里的东西。
What's in the basement?
地下室里有什么？
Monsters. Financial monsters.
怪物。金融怪物。
It was my best friend, Shane, who gave me the stock tip in 1997. And all the records are his basement where, symbolically enough, there are no lights.
是我的好朋友肖恩（Shane）在1997年给了我那个股票内幕消息。所有的记录都在他的地下室里，正如象征意义所暗示的那样，那里没有灯光。
Shane had never invested in anything either. He knew nothing about stocks, but he saw other people making money and he wanted in on the action. He called a good friend who he thought knew about this stuff, got a tip, and promptly called me.
肖恩以前也从未投过任何东西。他对股票一无所知，但他看到别人在赚钱，他也想参与进来。他给一个他认为懂行的好朋友打了电话，得到了消息，然后立刻打电话给我。
A Dirt Devil, a couple of bikes.
一台Dirt Devil吸尘器，几辆自行车。
I remember the phone call, but I was always fuzzy on what the company actually did. It was some kind of in-store, self-service beverage dispenser. Customers put an empty bottle under a nozzle, chose a flavor, and seconds later they had a full two-liter of off-brand juice or soda for a fraction of what it would cost in the soft drink aisle. Plus, it was organic or healthy or something. Frankly, I wan't paying all that much attention.
我记得那通电话，但我总是搞不清楚那家公司到底是干什么的。它是一种店内自助饮料机。顾客把空瓶子放在喷嘴下，选一种口味，几秒钟后，他们就能以软饮料货架上一小部分的价格，得到整整两升的非名牌果汁或苏打水。而且，它是有机或健康之类的。坦率地说，我当时没怎么注意。
They were going to be in stores all over the place. Shane said he was putting in 5,000. My total income that year, according to my '97 taxes, was $17,529, but I'd just gotten a big freelance check. I said put me down for 1,000. Finally, I thought, some of the boom will spill over onto me.
它们将遍布各地的商店。肖恩说他要投5000美元。根据我97年的报税单，我那一年的总收入是17529美元，但我刚收到一笔大额的自由职业支票。我说算我1000美元。我想，终于，繁荣的一小部分要溢到我身上了。
Taxes, '94, '99. That's going to be in there.
税务，94年、99年。应该在那儿。
Beneath some old dog beds, Shane finds a promising looking shoe box.
在一些旧狗窝下面，肖恩找到了一个看起来很有希望的鞋盒。
Oh, yeah.
噢，是的。
Well, this is the mother lode.
好吧，这可是金矿。
That'd survive an audit.
这足以通过审计了。
OK. This is the end of your statement. And this is on 7, 29, '97, we bought 1,400 shares of Fountain Fresh International, symbol FTFR, at $4.12-1/2 cents.
好的。这是你对账单的结尾。这是97年7月29日的，我们以每股4.125美元的价格买了1400股Fountain Fresh International，股票代码FTFR。
To help us sort through what happened to Fountain Fresh International, we've brought along our most financially astute friend, Mike Quattrocki, who does something involving lots of money and words like hedge funds, derivatives, and options, with the Chicago Board of Trade. Standing with his drink in stocking feet on Shane's unheated cellar floor, he's surrounded by old bicycles, rusty toolboxes, garbage bags filled with magazines, and Shane's financial records. He gets right to mockery.
为了帮助我们理清Fountain Fresh International到底发生了什么，我们请来了我们最懂金融的朋友，迈克·夸特罗基（Mike Quattrocki），他在芝加哥商品交易所做一些涉及大量资金、对冲基金、衍生品和期权之类词汇的工作。他站在肖恩冰冷的地下室地板上，穿着袜子，手里拿着饮料，周围堆满了旧自行车、生锈的工具箱、装满杂志的垃圾袋，还有肖恩的财务记录。他立刻开始了嘲讽。
Was this a high-technology play?
这算是一项高科技赌博吗？
No, no, no, no. No, no, no. No.
不，不，不，不。不，不，不。不。
It was not a technology play?
它不是科技股吗？
Well, the beverage center was high-tech, but it was not internet.
嗯，饮料中心是高科技的，但它不是互联网科技。
So, at the birth of the internet, you were buying beverage stocks?
所以，在互联网诞生之初，你们在买饮料股？
Yeah.
是的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I'd like to point out here that I've never even made enough money to lose as much as Mike did in the stock market. Plenty of his tech stocks went to zero too. He's mocking us not because we lost money, but because we lost it in a slightly different way than he and all his friends did.
我想指出，我从来没有赚够钱，以至于赔得像迈克在股市里那样多。他的许多科技股也都归零了。他嘲讽我们不是因为我们赔钱，而是因为我们赔钱的方式和他及其朋友们略有不同。
What's in there?
那里面有什么？
We bring the box back upstairs and begin to reconstruct what happened to the stock. With hindsight, there's a few things in the purchase certificate itself that don't bode well. Like the name of the brokerage house, Olde Discount: O- L- D- E. Mike has never heard of it. Shane chose it on the advice of the same friend who gave him the tip.
我们把盒子带回楼上，开始重建这只股票到底发生了什么。事后看来，认购证书本身就有一些预兆不祥的东西。比如经纪公司的名字，Olde Discount：O-L-D-E。迈克从来没听说过。肖恩是在给他消息的同一个朋友的建议下选择了这家公司。
I said, "Well, how do you buy a stock?" And he goes, "Well, you have to open a brokerage account, and you probably want to go to one of these discount places where the fees aren't high."
我说，“好吧，怎么买股票？”他说，“嗯，你得开一个经纪账户，你可能想去这些收费不高的地方。”
So you got this tip. And then the next thing you had to figure out was, I know the stock I want to buy, how do I actually buy it?
所以你得到了这个消息。然后下一件事你需要弄清楚的是，我知道我想买的股票，我到底该怎么买？
Exactly. And I look in the phone book, and there's a discount one, called Olde, and it's downtown.
完全正确。我在电话簿里查了一下，有一家折扣店，叫Olde，就在市中心。
That sounds really suspicious. Why didn't you just go to Fidelity? Why didn't you just-- what?
这听起来真的很可疑。为什么你不去富达（Fidelity）？为什么你不……什么？
Because it was low fees.
因为它手续费低。
Schwab or anything with a little name recognition.
嘉信理财（Schwab）或任何稍微有点名气的公司。
I know.
我知道。
I mean, Olde? I mean, did you actually write the check out to Olde when you bought the stock?
我的意思是，Olde？我的意思是，你买股票的时候真的给Olde开了支票吗？
I don't know. No. It was like a national chain. It was like the poor man's Schwab. It's easy that it doesn't exist. I'm betting money it's gone.
我不知道。没有。它就像一个全国性的连锁店。它就像穷人的嘉信。它不存在了也很容易理解。我敢打赌它肯定倒闭了。
We look. Olde's not in the phone book, but we do find something about it on the internet.
我们查了一下。电话簿里没有Olde，但我们在网上查到了一些关于它的信息。
--go down. That's the regulation press release in '98. What happened there? Oh. Today fined Olde Discount--
——下降。那是98年的监管新闻稿。那里发生了什么？哦。今天对Olde Discount处以罚款——
1.35 million and censured it in connection with the firm's sales practices.
135万美元，并因与公司销售行为有关而受到谴责。
Sales practices.
销售行为。
What?
什么？
Founder, Ernest Olde, also fined 500,000 and suspended.
创始人欧内斯特·奥尔德（Ernest Olde）也被罚款50万美元并被暂停执业。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It turns out that Olde Discount Corporation had been engaging in a fairly common brokerage scam in the '90s. They'd quote the customer one price, buy the stock at a lower price, and pocket the difference. Mike shakes his head.
事实证明，Olde Discount Corporation一直在参与90年代相当常见的经纪欺诈。他们给客户报一个价，用更低的价格买入股票，然后将差价中饱私囊。迈克摇了摇头。
Did anyone advise you when you went in there and said to alert you to the risks associated?
当你进去时，有人建议过你，提醒你相关的风险吗？
Yeah. Yeah. He said they're going to make you fill out a form. What is your tolerance for risk? Blah, blah, blah.
是的。是的。他说他们会让你填一张表格。你对风险的承受能力是多少？巴拉巴拉，巴拉巴拉。
$5,000, at the time, to you, was a lot of money.
5000美元，当时对你来说是一大笔钱。
A lot of money.
一大笔钱。
When you come in to a discount brokerage house, and you walk in off the sheet, I don't know what you looked like. I don't know how you were dressed, but you clearly were clutching your 5,000 and Alex's 1,000, and you came in with a very specific stock in mind. And you came in, and you queried about a stock that he had, surely, never heard of. And then you decided that you wanted to buy that stock. I'm sure alarm bells were clanging in his head, for sure.
当你进入一家折扣经纪行，直接从街上走进去，我不知道你当时看起来是什么样子。我不知道你怎么穿的，但你显然紧紧攥着你的5000和亚历克斯的1000美元，你带着一个非常具体的股票目标走了进去。然后你进去，询问了一只他肯定从没听说过的股票。然后你决定你要买那只股票。我相信他脑子里肯定敲响了警钟。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
It was shocking to hear Mike lay out the broker's perspective on this. Shane and I had never stopped to consider how we might have looked to someone who actually knew about this stuff. We knew we didn't know anything, but we had no idea just how clearly everyone else could see that.
听到迈克从经纪人的角度分析这一点真是令人震惊。肖恩和我从未停下来考虑过，在那些真正懂行的人眼中，我们看起来是什么样子。我们知道我们什么都不懂，但我们完全不知道其他人能看得如此清楚。
And if you walked in off the street with this $6,000, I would say, "Sonny, go home and save your money."
如果你们拿着这6000美元直接从街上走进来，我会说，“年轻人，回家存你的钱去吧。”
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I would say, as an honorable broker, that's what an honorable-- an honorable broker should not have processed this trade. He should have just said, "Go home. Don't buy this stock I've never heard of."
我会说，作为一个诚实的经纪人，这就是……一个诚实的经纪人是不应该处理这笔交易的。他应该直接说，“回家去。别买这只我从没听说过的股票。”
At some point during this dispiriting lesson on how not to buy a stock, it occurred to me that maybe things were worse than I'd even imagined. Maybe we hadn't just been foolish, maybe we'd been scammed. Maybe Fountain Fresh had never even existed. And so five years after the fact, and with my stock worth exactly 1/100 of a cent per share, I decided to do the research I should have done before I even bought it.
在这次关于如何不买股票的令人沮丧的教训中，某个时刻我意识到事情可能比我想象的还要糟糕。也许我们不仅仅是愚蠢，我们可能被骗了。也许Fountain Fresh甚至从未存在过。所以五年后，当我的股票价值正好是每股0.01美分的百分之一时，我决定做我甚至在买它之前就应该做的研究。
For a while, everything I learn is troubling. In the years between 1985 and 2000 it had at least eight different CEOs. Press releases from 1985 to 2000 all declare the same thing, that the company is just about to turn a profit, but not one says that the company actually has. Big new contracts with Walmart and various supermarket chains in Canada, Australia, and the Philippines, are constantly announced. But, mysteriously, revenue never goes up. I find no SEC filings on the company, no annual reports, no website. And then I find a December 2nd, 1995 article in the Modesto Bee. It says a Fountain Fresh machine was installed in the Sav Max Foods in Ceres, California.
有一阵子，我了解到的每一件事都令人担忧。在1985年到2000年间，它至少换了八任首席执行官。从1985年到2000年的所有新闻稿都宣称同一件事，即公司即将盈利，但没有一份说公司实际上盈利了。不断宣布与沃尔玛以及加拿大、澳大利亚和菲律宾的各种连锁超市签订大的新合同。但奇怪的是，营收从未上涨。我找不到这家公司的证券交易委员会（SEC）备案，没有年度报告，没有网站。然后我在1995年12月2日的《莫德斯托蜂报》（Modesto Bee）上发现了一篇文章。它说一台Fountain Fresh机器被安装在了加州塞雷斯的Sav Max食品店。
It was in the corner of the store in the back area because a lot of tubes had to go to it. All these tubes, because you imagine every tube had to do carbonation and then flavors. You know what I'm saying?
它就在店后面角落里，因为很多管道都要接到它那里。所有这些管道，因为你想想，每一根管道都必须进行碳酸处理，然后进行调味。你知道我的意思吗？
When I called the Sav Max store, the person who picks up the phone is Christine Arianne. I can't really tell you the relief I feel when she confirms that Fountain Fresh actually had a product. A product means that they must have had a factory to make it in, and sales people to sell it, and delivery people to deliver it. A product means that it wasn't a scam, it was an actual company that made actual things that actual people had actually seen. Christine talks to me while ringing up customers.
当我给Sav Max店打电话时，接电话的人是克里斯汀·阿里安（Christine Arianne）。当她确认Fountain Fresh确实有一个产品时，我感到的解脱真的无法言喻。有产品意味着他们肯定有一个工厂来制造它，有销售人员去卖它，还有送货人员去运送它。有产品意味着它不是骗局，它是一家真正的公司，生产人们真正见过、实际的东西。克里斯汀一边帮顾客结账一边跟我说话。
They had a blue ice flavor and a lemonade. They had an off-brand Coca Cola or Pepsi. I mean, it was kind of like you just put your soda underneath there and pushed the button that you wanted, and then it would just fill it up. And it filled it up cold.
他们有一种蓝色冰味和一种柠檬水味。他们有一种非名牌的可口可乐或百事可乐。我的意思是，这就像你把苏打水放在下面，按下你想要的按钮，然后它就会加满。而且它加满时是冰凉的。
Talk about, as far as you could tell, was it popular with the customers?
据你所知，它在顾客中受欢迎吗？
Yeah.
是的。
It was?
是吗？
Very popular. I think because it wasn't very expensive. It was like $0.69 to fill a two-liter, and I want to say $0.49 to fill a one-liter. It was a lot cheaper, so I think--
非常受欢迎。我想是因为它不是很贵。两升装加满只要69美分，一升装我想只要49美分。它便宜得多，所以我认为……
[INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]。
Oh yeah, she did. Where'd she go? She's got to come back. She just took her [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. I had a lady forget her groceries.
噢，是的，她做到了。她去哪了？她得回来。她只是拿了她的……[听不清]。我有一个女士忘记了她的杂货。
OK.
好的。
Yeah. So it did good. It went really well. As a matter of fact, a lot of people were all really bummed when it went out of business.
是的。所以它做得很好。它进行得非常顺利。事实上，当它倒闭时，很多人都感到非常失落。
They were?
他们是吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Did people actually come up to you and talk to you about it?
有人真的走过来和你谈论它吗？
Uh-huh. They were like, where'd it go? We were just getting the hang of that. Where'd it go? It just seemed like we had it and then, all of a sudden, it was gone.
嗯哼。他们说，它去哪了？我们才刚开始习惯。它去哪了？这就像我们拥有它，然后突然之间，它就没了。
The real go-go years for Fountain Fresh were right around the time they installed the machine in Christine's store. In '94, the stock had risen to its all time high, $9 a share. And in '96, a man named Richard Maynes took over as CEO. He was charismatic, capable, everyone loved him, and he set the company on an ambitious new path. To figure out how to better sell the product, he hired Doblin Incorporated, a consulting company so fancy that they called themselves--
Fountain Fresh真正腾飞的年份就在他们安装在克里斯汀店里那台机器的时候。94年，股价涨到了历史最高点，9美元一股。而在96年，一个叫理查德·梅恩斯（Richard Maynes）的人接任了首席执行官。他极具魅力、能力出众，每个人都喜欢他，他为公司开辟了一条雄心勃勃的新道路。为了搞清楚如何更好地销售产品，他雇佣了Doblin Incorporated，一家非常时髦的咨询公司，他们自称……
An innovation strategy firm.
一家创新战略公司。
Peter Laundy managed the Fountain Fresh project for Doblin, and he still says that Fountain Fresh had a great product. It was cheaper than regular soda. It took up less shelf space, which grocers liked. You could re-fill the same bottle over and over again, so it had an environmental angle. But its most important advantage had to do with distribution.
彼得·隆迪（Peter Laundy）为Doblin管理Fountain Fresh项目，他仍然说Fountain Fresh有一个很棒的产品。它比普通苏打水便宜。它占用的货架空间更少，这是杂货商喜欢的。你可以一遍又一遍地重复使用同一个瓶子，所以它还有环保的一面。但它最重要的优势在于分销。
It allowed you to bottle soda at the grocery store. And that was really efficient because soda is, basically, 95% water with a little sugar and flavoring added, and it's a whole lot cheaper to pipe water to a grocery store than to load it into bottles and truck it.
它允许你在杂货店装瓶苏打水。这真的很高效，因为苏打水基本上是95%的水加上一点糖和香精，把水管道输送到杂货店比装进瓶子里用卡车运输要便宜得多。
This idea of the bottled soft drink that doesn't need to be shipped turns out as something of a holy grail in the beverage industry. For years, people were trying to figure out a way to do it, Fountain Fresh succeeded. I told Shane about my conversation with Peter Laundy.
这种不需要运输的瓶装软饮料的想法，被证明是饮料行业的“圣杯”。多年来，人们一直试图找到一种方法来做到这一点，Fountain Fresh成功了。我告诉了肖恩我和彼得·隆迪的谈话。
So I talked to the guy from the Doblin Group yesterday, and he explained to me what the original genius was.
所以昨天我和Doblin集团的那个人谈过了，他向我解释了最初的天才之处是什么。
Was it the natural ingredients, or the reusable? Or what was the deal?
是天然成分，还是可重复使用？或者是什么？
He said that the original genius was that it had figured out a way to make a two-liter soda without having to ship it, basically.
他说最初的天才之处在于它找到了一种无需运输就能制作两升苏打水的方法，基本上。
Right. You ship an ounce of ingredients, and then you add the water when you get there.
对。你运输一盎司的配料，然后当你到了那里再加水。
Then the machine actually purifies the tap water, and then it mixes it all together. And it does it for you right there.
然后机器实际上会净化自来水，然后把所有东西混合在一起。而且它就在那里为你完成这一切。
I've got to say I would do it all over again. It's genius. There is a genius there.
我不得不说我会重来一遍。这是天才。那里确实有天才。
There is genius, and we don't even know the full genius. It's cheaper, it's way cheaper. Also he said that it's free advertising because, basically, you have a machine in the store, and he said that you can cover that machine, the face of that machine, with whatever image you want. And it's, basically, a huge surface. And he said the problem with Coke and other groceries is that the only picture you can put is on a tiny, two-liter bottle.
确实有天才，而且我们甚至不知道全部的天才。它更便宜，便宜得多。此外他还说这是免费广告，因为基本上，你在店里有一台机器，他说你可以覆盖那台机器，那台机器的表面，用你想要的任何图像。而且，基本上，它是一个巨大的表面。他说可乐和其他杂货店的问题在于你唯一能放图片的地方是一个小小的两升瓶子。
And yet, despite the problem of the tiny two-liter bottle, Coke and Pepsi still manage to pay their stockholders more than a penny a share.
然而，尽管有两升小瓶子的问题，可口可乐和百事可乐仍然设法支付给股东每股超过一分钱。
You can really, really do some good brand forming.
你真的、真的可以做一些很好的品牌塑造。
I explained to Shane how Doblin's first step was to give Maynes a story to tell investors so that he could raise money to finally put Fountain Fresh over the edge. They gave him a PowerPoint presentation and a fancy, wire-bound pitch, which he could take around to rich Wall Street types.
我向肖恩解释了Doblin的第一步是如何给梅恩斯一个故事去告诉投资者，这样他就能筹集资金最终让Fountain Fresh跨越障碍。他们给了他一个PPT演示和一份时髦的、铁丝装订的推介书，他可以带着它四处游说华尔街的有钱人。
The CEO did the typical late '90s suitcases full of cash, which Doblin went to work spending. They hired some of the fanciest industrial design firms around to redo the exterior of the machine. It was no longer going to be a non-descript, chunky box with spill stains down the front. It was going to be a sleek, beautiful box with spill stains down the front.
首席执行官做了90年代后期典型的“装满现金的手提箱”，Doblin去努力花掉这些钱。他们雇佣了一些最时髦的工业设计公司来改造机器的外观。它不再是一个不起眼的、粗笨的、前面沾满污渍的盒子。它将是一个时髦的、美丽的、前面沾满污渍的盒子。
So, how does an innovative concept backed by lots of cash go out of business? Eric Gillette was hired as the liaison between the high-priced designers in the East and the plant in Salt Lake City. When Shane and I talked to him, he said, "For one thing, there was a culture clash. The consultants back East were used to working with huge clients."
那么，一个有大量现金支持的创新概念是如何倒闭的？埃里克·吉列特（Eric Gillette）被聘为东部昂贵设计师与盐湖城工厂之间的联络人。当肖恩和我与他交谈时，他说：“一方面，存在文化冲突。东部的顾问习惯于与巨大的客户合作。”
They're heavy hitters. These are really smart people and they work for multimillion dollar contracts for big US corporations. And then the antithesis of that is this dumpy warehouse in Salt Lake, which was the headquarters for Fountain Fresh, and guys drive pickup trucks, and wear T-shirts, and have wrenches in their hand, you know? And so it's these two completely different cultures that were trying to pull this off.
他们是重量级人物。这些人非常聪明，他们为美国大公司的数百万美元合同工作。而与此截然相反的是盐湖城那个破旧的仓库，那是Fountain Fresh的总部，那里的家伙开着皮卡车，穿着T恤，手里拿着扳手，你知道吗？所以这两种完全不同的文化正试图实现这一点。
For a long time we were not even sure that Fountain Fresh ever existed as a company. So it's sort of comforting to hear you say that there actually was a warehouse with guys in T-shirts driving trucks.
很长一段时间我们甚至不确定Fountain Fresh作为一家公司是否存在。所以听到你说确实有一个有穿T恤家伙开卡车的仓库，这有点令人欣慰。
And that they had wrenches.
而且他们有扳手。
Yes. Exactly. Especially that they had wrenches.
是的。完全正确。特别是他们有扳手。
No. I mean, I think it had existed for a long time on this kind of really small level with these guys, basically, tinkering with this machine.
不。我的意思是，我认为它长期以来一直存在于这种非常小的水平上，这些人基本上是在摆弄这台机器。
What happened to Fountain Fresh is what happened to the US economy as a whole in the late 90s. Fountain Fresh was a bunch of regular guys trying to take a good idea and make a little money with it. Suddenly, these suits show up saying the idea is the next big thing. They rent out ballrooms and hire event planners for shareholder meetings. Talk about fundamental shifts in economic paradigms, convince everyone that their vision is real despite evidence to the contrary.
Fountain Fresh发生的事情就是90年代末美国经济整体发生的事情。Fountain Fresh是一群普通人试图想出一个好主意，并从中赚点小钱。突然，这些西装革履的人出现说这个主意是下一个大事件。他们租下宴会厅并聘请活动策划人召开股东大会。大谈经济模式的根本转变，让每个人都相信他们的愿景是真实的，尽管有证据表明并非如此。
The whole summer Fountain Fresh was preparing for their big roll out, their stock price was steadily dropping. And Shane and I knew it, we were watching, and we knew just what to do.
整个夏天Fountain Fresh都在为他们的大规模发布做准备，他们的股价在稳步下跌。肖恩和我都知道，我们看着，我们知道该做什么。
The one thing I had heard about investing, buy and hold. So you're not supposed to sell it, even when it goes down, especially when it goes down because that's what the suckers do.
关于投资我听过的一件事，买入并持有。所以你不应该卖出，即使它下跌时，特别是在它下跌时，因为那是傻瓜做的事。
Well, it makes sense, though, because if you thought well, if you still had faith in it, which we both did, we were so sure. I remember, for the whole first year, thinking well, it's going to bounce back.
嗯，这有道理，因为如果你想……嗯，如果你仍然对它有信心，我们两人都有，我们非常确定。我记得，整个第一年，都在想“嗯，它会反弹的”。
Well, the thing about those little investment chestnuts that they don't tell you is, for example, the buy and hold idea is premised on the theory that you've made a good decision in the first place.
嗯，关于那些小投资格言，他们没告诉你的是，例如，买入并持有的想法前提是假设你从一开始就做出了正确的决定。
So what went wrong? I tried to reach the eight presidents of Fountain Fresh. Several, I couldn't find. Others refused to talk on tape. But here's what I was able to piece together from people inside the operation.
那么哪里出了问题？我试图联系Fountain Fresh的八任总裁。有几位我找不到。其他人拒绝录音。但这是我从内部运作的人员那里拼凑出来的。
Explanation number one, the idea was actually bad. One of the ex-presidents in Fountain Fresh told me that they never figured out a way to do the most basic thing any business has to do, make a profit. "Even if the machines dispensed soda all day long," he said, "they still wouldn't have sold enough product to cover their costs." And even worse, everyone agreed that the wrench guys never figured out how to make the dispenser work right. They never came up with a design that could be mass-produced. Here's Eric Gillette.
第一个解释，这个主意实际上很糟糕。Fountain Fresh的一位前总裁告诉我，他们从未找到任何企业必须做的最基本的事情，即盈利。他说：“即使机器整天都在销售苏打水，他们也卖不出足够的量来覆盖成本。”更糟的是，每个人都同意扳手小组从未弄清楚如何使分配器正常工作。他们从未设计出可以大规模生产的产品。这是埃里克·吉列特。
When you actually looked at the guts of the machine, it kind of looked like tubes, and pipes, and parts, and it just was this jumble of technology. And there would always be dripping syrup coming out of these pipes. And it was just kind of, OK, what is this, and why is that dripping?
当你真正观察机器的内部时，它看起来就像一堆管子、管道和零件，它只是一堆技术杂乱。而且那些管子里总是会滴下糖浆。这简直就是……好吧，这是什么，为什么那在滴水？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And those kinds of conversations--
以及那种对话——
Why is that dripping is never a good question.
为什么那在滴水，从来都不是一个好问题。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Explanation number two, it wasn't supposed to succeed in the first place. One of the biggest investors in Fountain Fresh was a man whose businesses were the subject of an August, 2000 Wall Street Journal article about overseas stock scams. He also financed the business that was the exclusive distributor for Fountain Fresh products. To do this, he issued millions of dollars in stock, but a special kind that can only be sold overseas and isn't subject to the same regulations and scrutiny that normal stocks are. And the document he showed to these overseas investors told the story of Fountain Fresh.
第二个解释，它最初就不打算成功。Fountain Fresh最大的投资者之一是一个人，他的生意是2000年8月《华尔街日报》关于海外股票诈骗文章的主题。他还资助了Fountain Fresh产品的独家经销商。为了做到这一点，他发行了数百万美元的股票，但这是一种只能在海外出售、不受正常股票相同监管和审查的特殊股票。而他向这些海外投资者展示的文件讲述了Fountain Fresh的故事。
In a sense, this guy didn't need Fountain Fresh to succeed. He'd make his money whether it did or not. He only needed it to look like it could succeed. He needed to tell a convincing story about the holy grail of the beverage industry and how these fancy consultants and designers could reach it so he could sell his $10 million in stock offerings to Australian, Filipino, and Korean versions of me and Shane. He'd make his millions on the stock, not on the off-brand cola or Dr. Pepper. I couldn't locate him or his company to comment on any of this. If this was his plan, the guys in the factory and the suits at Doblin might never have even known about it.
从某种意义上说，这个人不需要Fountain Fresh成功。无论成败，他都能赚到钱。他只需要它看起来像能成功。他需要讲述一个关于饮料行业“圣杯”的动人故事，以及这些时髦的顾问和设计师如何能触及它，这样他就能把他那1000万美元的股票推销给澳大利亚、菲律宾和韩国版的我和肖恩。他在股票上赚他的几百万，而不是靠那个非名牌可乐或胡椒博士。我无法联系到他或他的公司来对此发表评论。如果这是他的计划，工厂里的家伙和Doblin的西装革履的人可能根本就不知道。
Explanation number three, random circumstance did it in. It turns out there are a lot of ways for a small company with a good idea to fail. Richard Maynes, the charismatic president who came on board in 1996, was, by many accounts, the glue holding Fountain Fresh together. He was from Salt Lake and could talk pipes with the guys in the shop, money with the guys on Wall Street, and theories of branding with the guys at Doblin, all with equal fluency.
第三个解释，随机情况导致它倒闭。事实证明，一家拥有好主意的小公司失败的方法有很多。1996年加入的极具魅力的总裁理查德·梅恩斯，在许多方面是支撑Fountain Fresh的粘合剂。他是盐湖城人，能和车间的家伙谈论管道，和华尔街的家伙谈论钱，和Doblin的家伙谈论品牌理论，同样流利。
He was also a devout Mormon, and sometime in the summer of 1997, right around the time Shane and I bought into his company, the Church sent him to do missionary work. Without him at the center, people say, the whole thing blew apart. I ran this notion by Shane.
他也是虔诚的摩门教徒，在1997年夏天的某个时候，就在肖恩和我入股他的公司前后，教会派他去做传教工作。人们说，没有他坐镇中心，整个事情就吹了。我把这个想法告诉了肖恩。
God is not on our side here.
上帝在我们这里并不占优势。
God was not on our side.
上帝不在我们这边。
If God is not on your side, how can you expect to make any money in the stock market?
如果上帝不在你这边，你怎么能指望在股市里赚到钱？
Right.
对。
We had no idea what we were doing.
我们根本不知道自己在做什么。
We had no idea of what we were up against.
我们根本不知道我们面临的是什么。
The Fountain Fresh warehouse at 2030 Redwood Road in Salt Lake City now sits empty. It's on the same lot as a window cleaning company and a small metallurgical factory, but no one at either place seems to remember what used to be in the vacant warehouse next door.
Fountain Fresh位于盐湖城红木路2030号的仓库现在空置着。它和一家洗窗公司及一家小型冶金工厂在同一个地块，但无论哪家公司的人似乎都不记得隔壁闲置的仓库过去是干什么的。
Fountain Fresh eventually got folded into another company which went quietly defunct. It still exists on paper, but all that remains, physically, are a bunch of files in a storage locker somewhere in Solana Beach, California. I imagine it doesn't look too different in there than Shane's basement.
Fountain Fresh最终被合并到另一家公司中，那家公司悄无声息地倒闭了。它在纸面上仍然存在，但物理上剩下的，仅仅是加州索拉纳海滩某个存储柜里的一堆文件。我想那里面看起来和肖恩的地下室没什么两样。
Alex Blumberg.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格。
[MUSIC - "I GOT PLENTY OF NOTHIN", BY SAMMY DAVIS, JR.]
[音乐 - "I GOT PLENTY OF NOTHIN", BY SAMMY DAVIS, JR.]
Act Three, The View From The Mop. Well, so far on our program, we've heard from the middle-class, from the stock-owning class, and now we turn to the people making minimum wage. About seven million Americans work at minimum wage, or near to it, right this minute. Two thirds of those people are not teenagers, by the way. The Federal minimum is $5.15 per hour, which works out to under $11,000 per year.
第三部分，来自拖把的视角。嗯，到目前为止在我们的节目中，我们听到了中产阶级的、持股阶级的观点，现在我们要转向拿最低工资的人。此时此刻，大约有七百万美国人拿着最低工资或接近最低工资的薪水。顺便说一句，这些人中有三分之二不是青少年。联邦最低工资是每小时5.15美元，算下来一年不到11000美元。
A guy who writes under the pen name Greg Tate wrote a book, which is really nothing more than a year by year account, one vignette after another, of things that happened to him in his minimum wage job as a janitor in a fast food burger place that, in the book, he calls The Burger Store. All names in his book are changed. He worked there for 11 years. Justin Kaufman reads excerpts for us.
一个以笔名格雷格·泰特（Greg Tate）写作的家伙写了一本书，那其实只不过是一部按年份记录的、一个接一个片段的记叙，讲述了他在一家快餐汉堡店做清洁工时的经历，他在书中称之为“汉堡店”。他书中的所有名字都改过了。他在那里工作了11年。贾斯汀·考夫曼（Justin Kaufman）为我们读了摘录。
It's September 7, 1985, my first day of working at The Burger Store as a janitor. The first thing I had to do was clean the stairs.
1985年9月7日，我在“汉堡店”做清洁工的第一天。我要做的第一件事是打扫楼梯。
1987, during August, everybody was trying to get rid of Ward, the store manager. He played favorites. He had Janie Mulder, Candy Rackson, and Samantha Corsman wrapped around his finger because they were good-looking.
1987年，8月期间，每个人都想摆脱店长沃德（Ward）。他偏心。他把珍妮·穆尔德（Janie Mulder）、坎迪·拉克森（Candy Rackson）和萨曼莎·科斯曼（Samantha Corsman）玩弄于股掌之间，因为她们长得好看。
Bob Hopson was tired of the way Ward was doing things. Some time during August he sent the store office a letter. The letter said, "My co-workers and I have a problem with Ward. He has the good-looking women wrapped around his finger. He does not treat the good workers fair. Whenever the store runs out of product, we tell him right away. He says he's going to order it. Then, as time goes by, we are still out of that certain product. We tell him again, and he gets mad and says, "Why didn't you tell me?" I just feel Ward is not a good store manager. Sincerely, Concerned Employee." Bob had the letter typed, that way no one could detect his handwriting.
鲍勃·霍普森（Bob Hopson）厌倦了沃德的做法。8月期间的某天，他给店办公室写了一封信。信中说：“我和同事对沃德有个问题。他把好看的女人玩弄于股掌之间。他对待好员工不公平。每当商店缺货，我们立刻告诉他。他说他会订货。然后，随着时间推移，我们仍然缺那个特定的商品。我们再告诉他，他就发火说：‘为什么不告诉我？’我只是觉得沃德不是个好店长。诚挚的，关心的员工。”鲍勃把信打印了出来，这样就没人能看出他的笔迹了。
The first week of June, night shift was leaving trash bags beside the dumpster. Trash bags were supposed to be put inside the dumpster. Brett was pissed. He said he was going to leave a note on the dumpster. I asked him what he was going to write. He said he was going to say, "Hey, you dumb asses. Throw the trash bags in the dumpster." He never got to it, so I wrote that note. The note said, "Hey, you dumb asses. Trash bags go inside the dumpster, not beside it or behind it." The note worked for one night.
6月的第一周，夜班的人总是把垃圾袋放在垃圾箱旁边。垃圾袋本来应该放进垃圾箱里的。布雷特（Brett）很生气。他说他要在垃圾箱上留张纸条。我问他要写什么。他说他要写：“嘿，你们这些蠢蛋。把垃圾袋扔进垃圾箱里。”他一直没去写，所以我写了那张纸条。纸条上写着：“嘿，你们这些蠢蛋。垃圾袋要放在垃圾箱里面，不是旁边或后面。”这张纸条管用了一个晚上。
Night shift caused me one problem the third week of June. Someone punctured a carton of caramel sundae topping. It leaked onto the shelf. The puncture was caused by someone sticking a pen or a pencil into the carton. The puddle of sundae topping was about a foot and a half in diameter. Of course, I had to clean it up.
夜班的人在6月的第三周给我制造了一个麻烦。有人扎破了一盒焦糖圣代配料。它漏到了架子上。这个洞是有人用笔或铅笔戳出来的。圣代配料的积水直径大约一英尺半。当然，我得清理它。
1988, during the third week of June, Dave, Jaris, and Cody were in the basement having a conversation. Cody was eating a piece of bacon. Dave saw Ward coming downstairs, so Dave went back upstairs. Ward caught Cody eating the bacon. That piece of bacon was going to be thrown away anyway, but according to Burger Store rules, eating expired food is considered stealing. Ward suspended Cody for a week.
1988年，6月的第三周，戴夫、贾里斯（Jaris）和科迪（Cody）在地下室聊天。科迪正在吃一片培根。戴夫看到沃德下楼，就回楼上了。沃德逮住科迪在吃培根。那片培根本来也要扔掉的，但按照汉堡店的规则，吃过期食品被认为是偷窃。沃德让科迪停职一周。
A few days later, Ken Beaker was on break. He had ordered a cheeseburger. Actually, he was fixing himself a double cheeseburger. Brenda Wiland caught him. She told Ward Ken had paid for a cheeseburger not a double cheeseburger. Ward fired him.
几天后，肯·比克（Ken Beaker）在休息。他点了一个芝士汉堡。实际上，他正在给自己做一个双层芝士汉堡。布伦达·威兰（Brenda Wiland）逮住了他。她告诉沃德，肯付的是芝士汉堡的钱，而不是双层芝士汉堡。沃德开除了他。
Earlier that week, Ward's car got egged. At the same time, Ward was giving Kerry Mullinger a hard time. Well, the night of July 23rd Kerry worked and Ward didn't. Kerry had an idea. Kerry decided he would really get back at Ward. He put on the outside reader board, "Ward sucks." I thought that was so funny along with everybody else.
那周早些时候，沃德的车被人砸了鸡蛋。与此同时，沃德一直在给克里·穆林格（Kerry Mullinger）找麻烦。好吧，7月23日晚上克里工作而沃德没工作。克里有个主意。克里决定他要狠狠报复沃德。他在外面的阅读板上写道：“沃德烂透了。”我觉得这和大家一样非常有趣。
The next morning, Ward found out what Kerry did. I heard Ward say to Mike, "Your job could be at stake if you don't tell me who put that on the reader board." Well, Ward got his information from Mike. He then fired Kerry. A day later, I worked my 10th day in a row. Mark asked me how I was doing. I said, "I'm tired."
第二天早上，沃德发现了克里做的事。我听到沃德对迈克说：“如果你不告诉我谁把那个写在板上的，你的工作可能不保。”好吧，沃德从迈克那里得到了信息。然后他开除了克里。一天后，我连续工作了第10天。马克（Mark）问我过得怎么样。我说：“我累了。”
On November 30th, Kip Durkowitz quit that day. He told Ward that in his office. Ward said, "No. You can't quit. We've got some busy times ahead and we need you." Kip said, "I quit." Ward got mad and said, "You're not quitting." and pushed Kip. Kip, angry, said, "I quit." and punched Ward in the nose. Ward landed in a chair. Ward said to Kip, "You'll never work in Peddleton again." Two days later, Kip was working at the local pizza place.
11月30日，基普·德科维茨（Kip Durkowitz）那天辞职了。他在办公室告诉了沃德。沃德说：“不。你不能辞职。我们要面临忙碌的时间，我们需要你。”基普说：“我辞职。”沃德生气地说：“你辞不了职。”并推了基普。基普愤怒地说：“我辞职。”然后打了沃德的鼻子一拳。沃德摔倒在椅子上。沃德对基普说：“你永远别想在佩德尔顿（Peddleton）工作了。”两天后，基普在当地的一家披萨店上班。
1989, during the first weekend in August there was a sign in the break room that said certain employees were going to get paid vacations. Well, come to find out, The Burger Store was not going to do that. Jay was pissed and wrote bull-- [BLEEP] on the sign. The sign was taken down the next day. The next weekend, another sign appeared in the break room. This sign said employees should bow down to their managers. The next day, the sign was taken down.
1989年，8月的第一个周末，休息室里有个牌子，说某些员工将获得带薪假期。好吧，结果发现，“汉堡店”并不会那样做。杰伊（Jay）很生气，在牌子上写了“胡……[消音]”。牌子第二天就被撤下了。接下来的周末，休息室里又出现了一块牌子。这块牌子说员工应该向经理下跪。第二天，牌子又被撤下了。
During mid-December, Darby was going out Trisha Bayland. About a week later, Trisha no-showed and Darby wrote her down as a no-show. Trisha found out about it and broke up with him.
12月中旬，达比（Darby）和特里莎·贝兰德（Trisha Bayland）约会。大约一周后，特里莎无故缺勤，达比把她记作“无故缺勤”。特里莎发现了，跟他分手了。
1990, in mid-June, the restrooms flooded. The drains had been stopped up. I put out of order signs on both restroom doors. Customers were still going in the restrooms. It was obvious they couldn't read English, so I put signs on both restroom doors that said, "Toilettes fermee." That means toilet closed in French. Surprisingly those signs kept the customers out of the restrooms.
1990年，6月中旬，洗手间淹水了。下水道堵住了。我在两个洗手间门上都贴了“暂停使用”的牌子。顾客们仍然进洗手间。很明显他们看不懂英语，所以我把牌子换成了法语的“Toilettes fermee”。这意味着洗手间关闭。令人惊讶的是，那些牌子确实让顾客远离了洗手间。
1992, in late September, it was 12:45. I was supposed to get off work at 1:00. Celia Brothing comes up to me and says, "Tony said for you to do the dishes right now." That was not my job. I was so pissed off. It was almost 2:00 before I could get off work. When I got home, I grabbed my shirt and ripped it to shreds. It was OK. I had another shirt.
1992年，9月下旬，12点45分了。我本该在1点下班的。西莉亚·布罗辛（Celia Brothing）走到我面前说：“托尼（Tony）让你现在去洗碗。”那不是我的工作。我非常生气。差不多2点我才能下班。回到家，我抓起我的衬衫，把它撕成了碎片。没关系。我有另一件衬衫。
During the later part of the first week of April, Carlton Jebbards threw a cup of Dr. Pepper at Lisa Jillard. The next day, Carlton asked Lisa for a date. Lisa, of course, turns him down.
4月第一周的后半段，卡尔顿·杰巴兹（Carlton Jebbards）朝丽莎·吉拉德（Lisa Jillard）扔了一杯胡椒博士饮料。第二天，卡尔顿约丽莎出去。丽莎当然拒绝了他。
About two weeks after Thanksgiving, I did not go on break until 11:00. I got called off my break twice to help them out. I wound up having to get ice for the front counter. You talk about being pissed off. I went downstairs and ripped my shirt to shreds. It was OK. I had another shirt hanging in the break room.
感恩节后大约两周，我直到11点才去休息。我休息时被叫走两次去帮忙。最后我不得不去为前台拿冰块。你说生气不生气。我下楼把衬衫撕成了碎片。没关系。休息室里还挂着另一件。
In early September, Devon returns to The Burger Store after a year and a half absence. The moment Devon came back, he would act all crazy. Whenever we loaded truck, he would put wrestling moves on boxes. Devon would say, "Hulk Hogan off the ropes. Boot to the head." I remember, one time, Devon power bombed an empty shortening container six times.
9月初，德文（Devon）在缺席一年半后回到“汉堡店”。德文一回来，就表现得非常疯狂。每当我们装车时，他就会在箱子上玩摔跤动作。德文会说：“绿巨人霍根（Hulk Hogan）跳下绳索。靴子踢向头部。”我记得有一次，德文连续六次对一个空起酥油罐进行炸弹摔。
When the truck driver threw plastic wrapping off the truck, Devon would wad the plastic wrapping up and drop back to pass. He would pass the plastic wrapping to himself, then he would run about 40 yards and say, "Touchdown!" He would sometimes take Leah's hand and start dancing with her. While he was dancing with Leah, he would sing Strangers in the Night . Devon had me laughing so hard I practically had tears in my eyes. There was never a dull moment when Devon was around.
当卡车司机从车上扔下塑料包装时，德文会把塑料揉成一团，退后传球。他会传球给自己，然后跑大约40码说：“达阵！”他有时会牵着利亚（Leah）的手开始和她跳舞。他和利亚跳舞时，会唱《陌路情缘》（Strangers in the Night）。德文让我笑得眼泪都快出来了。德文在的时候从来没有无聊时刻。
A few days later, Dobey and I got to talking. He said he had heard of me. I told him I had been at The Burger Store for nine years too long. He said, "No, you haven't." I said, "Oh, yes, I have." He said, "No, you haven't." I, angry, said, "Oh, yes I have." He said nothing else.
几天后，多比（Dobey）和我聊了起来。他说他听说过我。我告诉他我在“汉堡店”待了九年，待得太久了。他说：“不，你没有。”我说：“噢，是的，我有。”他说：“不，你没有。”我愤怒地说：“噢，是的，我有。”他没再说什么。
1995, in May, the pipe that had been leaking since 1986 finally got fixed. Before I get to my last day, I would like to tell you all the things that happened over the years, over, and over, again.
1995年，5月，自1986年以来一直漏水的管子终于修好了。在我讲到最后一天之前，我想告诉你们多年来发生的这些事情，一遍，又一遍。
Night shift would always wash the grill towels and the regular towels together. That was a no-no. Wayne would continue to drop things. He would make mess after mess. Sometimes he was called butter fingers. Certain people got away with certain things. A lot of times Judd would stand out at the back sidewalk. He would drink coffee and smoke a cigarette. I know he made $9 or $10 an hour. One time I said to myself I wish I had a job like that.
夜班总是把烧烤毛巾和普通毛巾洗在一起。那是不允许的。韦恩（Wayne）总是摔东西。他制造了一个又一个混乱。有时他被称为“黄油手”。某些人能逃脱某些惩罚。很多时候贾德（Judd）会站在后人行道上。他喝咖啡抽烟。我知道他每小时赚9或10美元。有一次我对自己说，我希望我有那样的工作。
My last day, June 12th, was finally here. Everything went really well that day, although Eva said something to me that I didn't like. She said, "Greg, I think you're making a mistake by quitting." I told her the mistake would be for me to stay here. I was getting nowhere working at The Burger Store.
最后一天，6月12日，终于到了。那天一切都很顺利，尽管伊娃（Eva）对我说了一些我不喜欢的话。她说：“格雷格，我觉得你辞职是犯了个错。”我告诉她，犯错的是我留在这里。我在“汉堡店”工作毫无进展。
1:00pm arrived. It was the end of an era. The sad thing was, when I left, I was only making $5.85 an hour. About two weeks after I quit, The Burger Store started hiring people at $6 an hour. A few people said that my quitting had nothing to do with Mark starting people at $6 an hour. My quitting had everything to do with it. Mark would never pay me $6 an hour even after I had been there 11 years, 9 months and 5 days.
下午1点到了。一个时代结束了。可悲的是，当我离开时，我每小时只赚5.85美元。我辞职后大约两周，“汉堡店”开始以每小时6美元的价格招聘员工。有些人说我辞职与马克以6美元价格招聘员工毫无关系。我辞职与此完全有关。马克永远不会给我6美元每小时的工资，即使我已经在那儿工作了11年9个月零5天。
The book is titled, 11 Years, 9 Months and 5 Days. Justin Kaufman read excerpts for us. The author goes under the pen name, Greg Tate. This book was self-published on xlibris.com. He now works as a janitor and maintenance worker at an elementary school. He makes almost twice as much as he did before, though he says the politics of the school are as tough as at The Burger Store.
书名是《11年9个月零5天》。贾斯汀·考夫曼为我们读了摘录。作者使用了笔名格雷格·泰特。这本书在xlibris.com上自费出版。他现在在一家小学做清洁工和维修工。他赚的钱几乎是以前的两倍，尽管他说学校的政治氛围和“汉堡店”一样艰难。
[MUSIC - "SUPPLY & DEMAND" BY THE HIVES]
[音乐 - "SUPPLY & DEMAND" BY THE HIVES]
Well, our program was produced today by Wendy Dorr and myself with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Dave Kestenbaum, and Starlee Kine. Senior Producer: Julie Snyder. Production help from Katie O'Donnell, Kelsey Dilts, and Todd Bachmann.
嗯，我们今天的节目由温迪·多尔（Wendy Dorr）和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、黛安·库克（Diane Cook）、戴夫·凯斯滕鲍姆（Dave Kestenbaum）和斯塔莉·基恩（Starlee Kine）参与。高级制作人：朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。凯蒂·奥唐奈（Katie O'Donnell）、凯尔西·迪尔茨（Kelsey Dilts）和托德·巴赫曼（Todd Bachmann）提供了制作协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our programs for free or buy CDs of them. Or you know you can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife, where they have public radio programs, bestselling books, even the New York Times, all at audible.com.
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们的节目或购买CD。或者你知道，你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们节目的音频，那里有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至《纽约时报》，都在audible.com。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金支持鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. We all asked him if we could have this weekend off, work five days this week instead of seven. His reply.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责。我们都问他能否休息这个周末，这周工作五天而不是七天。他的回复。
You're not willing to work? I don't know anything to call that but lazy.
你不愿意工作？我不知道除了懒惰还能称为什么。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "SUPPLY & DEMAND" BY THE HIVES]
[音乐 - "SUPPLY & DEMAND" BY THE HIVES]
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际公司。